okay so in this presentation we're going
to discuss enzymes so let's go ahead and
get started well before we discuss
exactly what enzymes are we need to
understand a little bit about chemical
reactions no chemical reactions will
absorb and release energy the picture
kind of shows the chemical reaction the
very basics of nuclear fusion and in
nuclear fusion energy is absorbed and
energy is released in order for a
chemical reaction to occur energy is
added to start the chemical reaction and
this this is called the activation
energy the amount of energy needed to
start a chemical reaction you know the
analogy you'll often see is this person
pushing a boulder up a hill the amount
of energy it takes for the person to get
the boulder to the top of the hill is
the activation energy once the boulder
reaches the top and the guy can give it
one final push the boulder will fall on
its own the chemical reaction would then
proceed on its own once the activation
energy has been added to get the
reaction started you'll see more of this
guy in a few moments so when chemical
reactions proceed energy is released
usually in the form of heat and light
energy is released because chemical
bonds are broken during a chemical
reaction so a good example is this
chemical formula right here ATP which
you might know is adenosine triphosphate
which is a energy molecule that our
cells will break down for energy so ATP
with the addition of water when you
bring the two together and when enzymes
are included we'll talk more about
enzymes in just a few moments then
energy is released when ATP is broken
down into a DP the energy that comes out
is in this case in the form of heat and
this is the heat that is used to warm
our body so our cells do this example
right here
so there's a couple chemical reaction a
couple types of chemical reactions I
want to discuss one is called exothermic
chemical reactions when you break the
word into prefix and suffix you know EXO
means to release or to give off thermic
implies heat so the word literally means
to give off heat so the definition of an
exothermic reaction it's a chemical
reaction that will release more energy
than it takes in or then it absorbs and
so when the energy is given off it's
usually in the form of heat or usually
in the form of light and so a great
example of an exothermic chemical
reaction is cellular respiration the
process that breaks glucose down to make
cellular energy here's the formula for
for for cellular respiration c6h12o6 on
the left that's glucose with the
addition of oxygen will yield carbon
dioxide water in energy energy for from
cellular respiration is in the form of
ATP adenosine triphosphate but this is
why it's an exothermic reaction energy
is released in the products of the
chemical reaction when we talk about the
opposite we're talking about endothermic
reactions no endo is a prefix that means
to take in or to absorb thermic again
implies Heat so when you look at the
definition of endothermic it's a
chemical reaction that takes in or
absorbs more energy than it will release
a great example of this is
photosynthesis I'm sure you all know
that photosynthesis takes in sunlight
energy to break down to to create sugar
excuse me to create sugar and glucose
that the plant will use for food when
you look at the general formula of
photosynthesis you see that carbon
dioxide and water and light sunlight
energy are used to produce sugar and
oxygen again this is a great example why
photosynthesis is an endothermic
reaction sunlight is taken in to help
jumpstart
this process so I'm going to talk about
what catalysts are and this is going to
lead us directly into enzymes so a
catalyst is a substance that will lower
or decrease the activation energy needed
to start a chemical reaction you know
what if you're this person pushing the
boulder if somehow the hill could be
flattened and not so steep you would not
need to spend so much energy pushing
that Boulder over the edge well that's
kind of what a catalyst does a catalyst
will lower the energy needed to start a
chemical reaction when you look at this
graph right here this graph will show
exactly what I'm Shoni what I'm
referring to so the red line shows the
energy that is needed for a chemical
reaction to occur notice how the red
line will increase and eventually begin
the decrease near the end of the graph
well what this red hump is here this is
the activation energy this is the energy
that needs to be added in order for the
reaction to occur but with a catalyst
notice how the graph is different with a
catalyst the activation energy is much
less the hump to get the chemical
reaction started is much smaller so
that's what a catalyst does now what are
catalysts well heat is a great example
of a catalyst so why don't we just heat
the body up to help start all of our
chemical reactions whoo I hope you see
danger in that idea
you really can't warm up the human body
just a couple degrees above normal
lands us in bed and we're sick and we
have a fever and we feel miserable
that's just with a few degrees above
normal so there's a reason why heat is
not used by cells as a catalyst I want
to explore that a little more depth why
heat is not used by ourselves as a
catalyst well here's a good example
here's one amino acid here's a second
amino acid here's a third and here's a
big growing chain of amino acids you
might know already that a big chain of
amino acids makes up a bigger molecule
called a protein proteins are super
important in maintaining our body in our
cells so pretend that amino acid 9 is
attracted amino acid 20 what happens is
the chain of amino acids will twist and
fold and Bend towards whichever they're
attracted to pretend amino acid 1 is
attracted to amino acid 5 ok
and finally pretend amino acid 13 is
attracted to amino acid 1 proteins have
a final shape that will allow them to
perform their function and the shape of
a protein is very precise if the shape
of a protein is altered in any way the
protein typically cannot perform its
function now this is a given to the
reason why heat is a bad catalyst for
cells so why don't we use heat as a
catalyst
well the notes say that proteins which
are again very important molecules it
within our cells and within our bodies
proteins will degrade and break down and
denature when they are exposed to higher
than normal temperatures
so if heat were used as a catalyst this
would happen the protein would break
apart the protein would no longer be
able to function because its shape has
been changed and this would lead to
eventually a stopping of chemical
reactions within our bodies and
eventually our death so now we're coming
to enzymes enzymes are the catalysts
that are used by cells enzymes are
involved in almost every chemical
reaction within the body the picture of
potatoes is because potatoes are full of
a polysaccharide called start starch
is very common to potatoes so let's zoom
out in and so here's a very simplistic
diagram of starch a big chain of glucose
molecules and so there's an enzyme by
the name of amylase amylase is an enzyme
that will kind of act like scissors and
will digest and break down starch into
the individual monosaccharides so the
enzyme here are the animated scissors
and the enzyme amylase which is the
specific enzyme in this example will
continue to break down the starch into
smaller individual glucose molecules
into smaller monosaccharides and so
again because enzymes are a catalyst
they lower the energy needed to start a
chemical reaction
they will also increase the speed or the
rate in which the chemical reaction will
occur this specific reaction is this
important reaction right here with the
breakdown of starch and other chemical
reactions this process would be just way
too slow to sustain life without the use
of a catalyst if we talked about this
specific reaction of the breakdown of
starch this is not an exaggeration
starch is literally broken down a
million times faster with the presence
of the enzyme called amylase let's look
at the structure of enzymes
first of all enzymes are proteins so
again here's a big chain of amino acids
and because enzymes are proteins the
enzyme will twist and fold and bend into
a final shape and that shape will
ultimately help the enzyme perform its
function so here's a very simplistic
diagram of the final shape of an enzyme
notice how those little grooves cut out
on top that's going to be really
important
so the enzyme the shape of the enzyme
will actually attract very specific
molecules and the molecules that enzymes
will attract are called the substrate
notice how there's like a v-shape
channel and kind of like a peg shaped
channel at the top of the enzyme well
here's a substrate that the enzyme is
attracting and so that those V shape
that v-shaped cutout location on the
enzyme and that peg like cutout of the
enzyme this is called the active site
this is the location where the substrate
will actually bind to and connect with
the enzyme so the analogy you'll often
see is that the active site and the
substrate are kind of like a lock and a
key when the two fit they connect and
they bind with one another so in my
example of course here we see the
substrate has binded to the enzyme well
now what the enzyme will actually weaken
and break the bonds that are holding the
substrate together and ultimately there
you see the substrate has been digested
and broken down so what if the substrate
does not match the active site well
here's another substrate notice how the
shape of this substrate is very
different than the grooves and notches
that you see on the enzyme notice what
happened nothing
no reaction will occur enzymes are very
specific they match to a specific
substrate so if the substrate and the
active site don't match no chemical
reaction will occur so a good example
again I brought this up a few moments
ago is the digestion of starch by an
enzyme called amylase so here's the
enzyme called amylase again
simplistically and here's starch because
starch is going to bind with this enzyme
that makes starch the sub
notice how the active site has the
grooves that perfectly match the starch
substrate and so because they match and
they bind with one another what's going
to happen next is the enzyme animes kind
of acts like my animated scissors from a
few moments ago the enzyme amylase will
break down and digest the starch into
smaller individual units so if you're in
my biology class you're learning the
difference between a hydrolysis reaction
and a dehydration synthesis reaction so
I want to kind of go over the role that
enzymes play in this so here is a
drawing a chemical drawing of sucrose
for simplicity I'm going to draw it like
this right here and what you see is that
sucrose is a substrate and it will match
into an enzyme into the active site of
an enzyme and with the addition of water
the addition of water and the action of
the enzyme will help to break sucrose
into two smaller fragments one called
glucose the one on the left is glucose
and the one on the right is fructose so
this is kind of the role that enzymes
play in hydrolysis well let's look at
the role that enzymes play in
dehydration synthesis here's a molecule
of glucose on the left for simplicity
I'm just going to draw it as a hexagon
shape and here's fructose on the right
for simplicity I'm just going to draw it
as a Pentagon so here is an enzyme that
will have a proper active site for
glucose and fructose glucose and
fructose would be the substrates so here
we see glucose and fructose fitting into
the active site of the enzyme now the
reason this is called a dehydration
synthesis reaction is because water will
be removed watch this water is removed
and in the process of that happening the
glucose and the fruit the
is bonded together to make sucrose a
larger molecule when we look at the
structure of sucrose here we can see
it's one large molecule held together by
that oxygen bond in the middle so this
is the role that enzymes can play in
building molecules as well not just
breaking them down so there you have it
I hope you found this video to video to
be helpful if you're in my biology class
feel free to pause the video write these
answers down on a separate sheet of
paper and I'd be happy to check your
answers either before or after class
thanks for watching